♪♪
Narrator:
THIS THAW-AND-SERVE LEMON TART
HAS A SHORTBREAD SHELL
AND CREAMY LEMON FILLING
TOPPED WITH BUTTERCREAM.
EACH BATCH OF DOUGH PRODUCED
IN THIS INDUSTRIAL MIXER
YIELDS 449 TART SHELLS.
THE FIRST STEP IS TO LIGHTLY
BLEND MARGARINE, SUGAR, AND SALT
FOR TWO OR THREE MINUTES.
NEXT, ADD PASTEURIZED EGGS,
AND MIX FOR ABOUT TWO MINUTES
AT SLOW SPEED.
FAST MIXING MAKES THE DOUGH
TOO TIGHT, CAUSING IT TO CRACK.
THEY ADD WHITE FLOUR
WHILE CONTINUING TO MIX SLOWLY,
UNTIL THE INGREDIENTS
ARE WELL-BLENDED.
ONCE THE DOUGH IS READY,
WORKERS PUT IT THROUGH
WHAT IS ACTUALLY A
HAMBURGER-FORMING MACHINE.
IT EXTRUDES
1/4-POUND DOUGH PATTIES.
WORKERS PLACE THEM IN THE MIDDLE
OF A NON-STICK ALUMINUM TART PAN
THREE AT A TIME.
THEY MOUNT THE PAN ON A PRESS,
COVERING IT WITH PLASTIC.
A DIE STRIKES THE PAN,
FLATTENING AND SPREADING
THE DOUGH EVENLY.
THE PANS GO INTO THE OVEN, WHERE
THEY ROTATE FOR 23 TO 24 MINUTES
AT 350 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT.
THE DEPOSITOR IS PRE-SET
TO SQUIRT 22 OUNCES
OF LEMON FILLING IN EACH TART.
THE FILLED TARTS GO
INTO THE OVEN FOR 11 MINUTES.
THE LEMON TARTS
COME OUT OF THE OVEN,
COOL AT ROOM TEMPERATURE
FOR TWO TO THREE HOURS,
THEN GO INTO A FREEZER
OVERNIGHT.
THE NEXT DAY, WORKERS REMOVE
THE FROZEN TARTS FROM THE PANS.
NEXT, THEY PUT THE TART
IN AN AUTOMATED CAKE SLICER.
THE TURNTABLE ROTATES AS
THE TART IS CUT INTO 12 SLICES,
WITH PAPERS IN BETWEEN EACH ONE.
THIS IS FOR RESTAURANTS WHO
SERVE THE DESSERT BY THE SLICE.
WORKERS EMBELLISH EACH SLICE
WITH A FLOWER
MADE OF BUTTERCREAM --
A DECADENT MIXTURE OF BUTTER,
EGG WHITES, AND SUGAR.
THEY COMPLETE EACH FLOWER
WITH A DOT OF LEMON FILLING
IN THE CENTER.
THIS LEMON TART IS FINISHED.